[Music]
savine thank you so much for joining me
so what's gone wrong with physics so
physics
is a very large discipline that has a
lot of sub
most of which are going perfectly fine
you know we're talking about stuff like
um material science or plasma physics
or optics quantum optics and so on so
these are not the areas that i'm
concerned with i'm talking specifically
about the foundations of physics
that's the part where we deal with the
really big
questions like what is space what is
time what is meta made of
and so on and in these areas we just
haven't made progress since the 1970s
uh which brings up the question well why
so so one answer that for instance like
to give is that
uh we're just facing very very difficult
questions right and it takes a lot of
time to figure out uh
what's really going on um that's
certainly part of the story but it
doesn't really explain why
why the physicists in these disciplines
have
come up with so many theories that all
turned out to be wrong
um and i think that requires explanation
and
the explanation that i think is the most
plausible one
is that they are just not learning from
their mistakes so they're using very
specific
methods to develop new theories
and they're just not working and
specifically they
are using very restrictive notions of
mathematical beauty
so they construct theories that have to
comply with these ideas of mathematical
beauty and it's just not working
and so that's my answer to the question
what's what's going wrong with physics
could we talk about a couple of theories
which are two
based on outdated ideas of mathematical
plotting
this idea that um the fundamental forces
have to be unified
so that there is one big unified force
so we currently deal with
four different fundamental forces that's
the
electromagnetic force the strong and the
weak nuclear force and then there's
gravity
and physicists speak of a grand unified
force
if you combine everything except for
the gravitational force and there are
specific theories for that
they're called grand unified theories
and people have
you know tried to find evidence for that
since um the 1980s
uh instead they have ruled out uh lots
of these ideas
but physicists haven't given up on the
idea it's just too beautiful
you know um so this is one of these
ideas uh then there is
um supersymmetry um which has also been
around since the 1980s
people started uh looking for this
already with the large
electron positron collider and then with
the tavatron
in the united states and um now with uh
the lhc
and they haven't found it over and over
again but they
they they're not giving up on the idea
because it's just too it's just too
beautiful i suppose
um and so i just think that this is not
a good strategy uh to proceed it doesn't
lead us anywhere
um you have to learn from the results
that you get that's how science works
so what does a messy approach to physics
prioritize where does the funding go for
you what what are you looking at
what am i looking at specifically so
yeah so so i i should put ahead that i'm
always very careful if people
ask me that because of course i have a
personal opinion what we should be doing
but really my point is not that everyone
should be doing what i think is great
and the problem is that we're not having
a discussion about what is going
wrong so i think this community needs to
have a hard
look at itself and just think
more about the question where to best
put the money
but since you're asking me in particular
unsurprisingly i think
there should be more money invested in
exactly the stuff that i work on
so that's uh for one um that's
modifications of gravity so that's an
alternative explanation for
um dark matter so dark matter
is a hypothesis that physicists have
come up with to explain some puzzling
things we see out in the cosmos
that i can talk about in great detail
but it may take
take me several hours um and so
um the the idea that there is a certain
type of matter that we just have not
been able to produce and detect on earth
is one way
um to explain these observations um the
alternative
is that there's something about gravity
that we're misunderstanding so we
need a better theory of gravity and
that's what's called modified gravity so
this is one of the things that i
um work on which i think is very um
promising um so people have
looked for these supposed particles that
make up dark matter but none of them
have been found
uh and it's looking less and less and
appealing
every year there are more null results
so i think that it's
a natural point in time where more
effort
should be made to look for modified
gravity
and there is just on the theoretical
side there has been very little work
because
uh most people have focused on this
particle dark matter
idea so so that big gaps in our
understanding
um just exactly what for example you
should look for experimentally
how could you even tell these things
apart what you know what experiments
should you even make and and so there
you need some uh theoretical
investigation of that to even know
what what exactly you are looking for
and
the other um research area that i've
become increasingly interested in are
the foundations of quantum mechanics
um so there is um an assumption
in um one of the most important theorems
in that area which is called the free
will assumption
um and i think this assumption is just
wrong and it has to go out of the window
and it's really standing in the way of
progress
um it's why we have not been able to
make sense of quantum mechanics
you know there's this debate that has
been going on for
a century um how do we understand
quantum mechanics what does he mean
you know what does it say about the role
of the observer does human consciousness
play a role in the measurement process
and all that kind of stuff and i think
it's this this free will assumption
is standing in the way can you expand on
that
uh yes so i'm talking specifically about
something that's called bell's
theorem uh belt theorem plays
a very essential role in quantum
mechanics
because it tells you that
if you are trying to replace quantum
mechanics
with a theory that works the same way
that
all pre-quantum theory worked like a
newtonian mechanics basically
where you have a deterministic evolution
uh given by some differential equation
that works on an initial state okay so
that's a little bit of mathematics
but the point is that these pre-quantum
theories have a particular mathematical
structure that quantum mechanics just
has not in quantum mechanics you have
this random element
so in quantum mechanics the the
randomness that you have is not because
you're missing some information
the way that it would be the case if you
throw dice
for example but the randomness in
quantum mechanics is supposedly
fundamental it's not because you're
lacking information it's just
the way the universe is and so
belt's theorem tells you that you cannot
replace this randomness in quantum
mechanics with a lack of information
this is what is called a hidden
variables theory
where you say well quantum mechanics is
just not the end of the story
but the reason that it looks like
there's something random happening is
that we're just
you know we're missing something there's
a deeper underlying structure
uh where there is this information that
if we had it would actually tell us
exactly what the measurement outcome is
and so that's the relevance
uh of bell's theorem and now um the
so maybe uh let me tell you more
precisely what the theorem says
so uh it says that if you have such a
hidden variable theory
um then uh in a certain type of
experiment
that correlations that have to obey an
inequality
that spells inequality but you can
experimentally show that this inequality
is violated
and so the conclusion from all that is
that
you rule out these hidden variables um
ideas and so um that's why
people think that we have to accept that
nature is just not deterministic and
that it's not local in the way that
einstein wanted it and so on
but and here come back to this issue
with the free will assumption
um this theorem um as any mathematical
theorem
requires a list of assumptions one of
which is this free will assumption which
basically says
that the experimenter is free to choose
the detector setting whichever way they
like so that's how it's usually
interpreted
and the problem with that is is um i
mean on the face of it it's just
inconsistent you know you're basically
postulating that the theory is not
deterministic and then you use the
argument from birth theorem to conclude
that it's not deterministic which makes
absolutely no sense
um so i've been investigating the
question what happens
if you throw out this free will
assumption in which case
belt theorem just does not follow so
this idea
is not a new it's something that worse
um
you know people have been thinking about
already in the 1950s it goes under the
name
super determinism um and
for a long time people have thought that
yes it's technically an option like
mathematically it's there
of course you can just throw out this
assumption but
it's unscientific uh because such a
theory
would never be predictive um that was
the idea so people called it a
conspiracy theory
because um if you wanted to make any
prediction with
with such a theory then you would have
to put
all the information about the
measurement outcome uh
into the theory already so you can't
predict anything with it
and if that was the case it would indeed
be non-scientific but the the thing is
you don't have to do that so that this
argument is just
wrong and um you know basically just
last week i finished
a calculation with my postdoc that shows
an explicit counter example
to this claim so super determinism is
definitely not a conspiracy theory or
unscientific in the sense that people
have thought
for various decades and i think that's a
very that's a very important result
because it opens the doors
to replacing quantum theory with a more
fundamental with a better theory
in which you could actually calculate
the outcome of a quantum measurement
which
um most physicists believe today is just
not possible but you have to do
dedicated experiments uh to actually get
there
and so i think that's very important
because
in all these fancy technological devices
uh
including the ones that we just
communicate with
our ultimately based on quantum
mechanics they wouldn't work without
quantum mechanics
so certainly if we were able to replace
this theory with a better theory that's
more predictive
that allows us to calculate new effects
allows us to do new things
that would be super important um also
for technological
applications so i'm a theorist myself
you know i come more from this
uh the question like how does the
universe work can i describe it with
mathematics
but of course it has this um
technological aspect to it
could you tell us any more about the
calculation that you finished in the
last week with your postdoc or is that
something that needs to await
and if if not let's talk about the
technological application well i i
i'm hoping that so we're in the final
round of checking the calculations i
just hope that nothing dramatically goes
wrong there
um so um the the idea is that
um this is a very simple example
is what was called a toy model um in in
the literature
um that demonstrates explicitly that you
can have
a super deterministic model that exactly
reproduces the predictions of quantum
mechanics but does not require any fine
tuning
now the thing about this this toy model
is that it's not any better than quantum
mechanics because the only thing it does
for you is that it reproduces exactly
the same thing
but it demonstrates that this argument
is wrong
that uh super determinism is necessarily
unscientific
and so that's what it's good for and
then we're we're working on a more
complicated model that would actually
allow you to do
more predictions than quantum mechanics
and we hope
um to be able to say exactly what kind
of experiment you need to make to
actually
test this and then of course i hope i'll
be able to convince someone to actually
do this experiment
you're a very skilled communicator do
you feel an obligation to communicate
science to the public as a result
yes basically um is partly because
i have for the past
let me think 10 years or so i've been
working
almost 15 15 years at research
institutes
so not at public universities so i don't
have teaching obligations
and i kind of think that
i should do something to spread the
knowledge that we have gathered
in our research and so
i use the opportunities that social
media give me
um to tell the broader public uh
what we have learned well
you've communicated it brilliantly to me
without phd so thank you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you